wie dem auch sei viel etwas ukraine sein
da ist etwas passiert was wieder damit
zusammenhängt dass die außenpolitiker
und andere die zuständig waren sich mit
der geschichte des landes nie
beschäftigt
sie haben sich nie damit beschäftigt
dass sich die weste und die ost ukraine
zum beispiel auch im zweiten weltkrieg
ich will gar nicht näher darauf eingehen
völlig unterschiedlich verhalten haben
sie haben sich nie damit beschäftigt was
da auch die vigo russlands war
sie haben sich nicht beschäftigt mit der
bedeutung der krim für russland und
deshalb ist folgendes passiert russland
wollte die ukraine an sich ziehen und
die eu wolle die ukraine an sich ziehen
und der ganze konflikt ist dann so
eskaliert dass für die gegenwärtige
situation haben und dabei hätte die
ukraine eine chance gehabt dass sie die
brücke geworden wäre zwischen der eu und
russland
wenn man das erkannt hätte wenn man
rechtzeitig mit russland gesprochen
hätte auch deren sicherheitsinteressen
respektiert und gesagt hätte
lasst uns nicht zerren an der ukraine
sondern lasst uns gemeinsam für eine
brückenfunktion streiten wie anders
hätte die entwicklung aussehen können
als sie jetzt aussieht
und deshalb mache ich einen solchen
zeiten auf ungewöhnliche vorschläge und
habe gesagt wenn man jetzt mit putin
verhandeln will muss man doch jemanden
schicken zudem putin vertrauen hat
natürlich braucht deren auftrag der eu
deshalb hab ich grad schröder
vorgeschlagen weil ich weiß dass sie ein
gutes verhältnis zueinander haben
wenn wir da einen anderen hinschicken
hätte doch gar nicht zu der block der
sich doch von vornherein ab das bringt
doch nichts und umgekehrt habe ich
gesagt ich kenne keinen europäer der
wirksam in der ukraine zwischen den
unterschiedlichen teilen vermitteln kann
weil wir sind alle vorbelastet entweder
stehen beim eher auf der seite oder mehr
auf der seite und dann heißt es immer
die andere seite vertraut uns nicht
deshalb habe ich gesagt in der ukraine
brauchen wir ein vermittler wie kofi
annan weil der ist nicht verbraucht
beide seiten könnten sich auf ihn
einlassen er kann zuhören und er kann
versuchen zu vermitteln
und wenn krieg keine lösung ist und das
habe ich ganz klar gesagt auch gegen
russland das ist natürlich völlig absurd
wenn leute daran denken dass die nato
einmarschiert ich bitte euch dann haben
wir den ganzen kalten krieg überstanden
um jetzt in den dritten weltkrieg zu
schleudern
dass es ja völlig absurd das darf auf
gar keinen fall
damit ich nicht falsch verstanden werden
wann ich baue auf was man der spaltung
der ukraine gesagt habe dass es nicht
etwas was ich mir wünsche
ich sehe nur die gefahr denn ich habe
mir die anwesende ukrainerin gefragt
gibt es eine politische persönlichkeit
in der ukraine wo sie meint darauf
könnten sich beide teile der ukraine
verstellen
da hat sie gesagt nein das ist das
problem
deshalb sage ich die eu hat da alles
falsch gemacht was man falsch machen
kann
russland hat auch vieles falsch gemacht
man sagen auch alles falsch gemacht
jetzt haben wir die situation
und jetzt müssen sie sich bewegen und
dazu braucht man wieder ein anderes
verständnis des europäischen hauses es
gibt kein europa ohne osteuropa es gibt
auch kein europa ohne russland statt
sich jetzt sanktionen zu überlegen den
ganzen konfrontation doch nur verhärten
und verschärfen muss man endlich wieder
ein vertrauensverhältnis herstellen
damit dieser konflikt gelöst wird und
zwar so schnell wie möglich gelöst wird
und zwar gerade im interesse der
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
und übrigens auch für solche fragen ist
es wichtig dass die linke im
europaparlament stärker wird damit wir
mehr einfluss haben mehr gehört werden
mehr anrichten können in einem positiven
sinne des wortes und ich weiß die
menschen interessieren sich in unserem
land noch zu wenig für die europawahlen
aber alle erleben doch folgendes da
kommt man zum bürgermeister und dann
sagt man über warum kümmert das nicht so
und so vernünftig machen sagte das geht
nach dem europarecht nicht dann kann man
wieder geht man hat keine ahnung ob das
stimmt oder nicht stimmt und ich sag
euch in der hälfte der fälle stimmt in
der anderen hälfte ist es frei erfunden
aber das macht ja nicht man kann das gar
nicht unterscheiden es ist so eine
abstrakte größe das ist den leuten
unheimlich aber wenn europarecht wichtig
ist da muss man sich auch an europa
wahlen beteiligen damit dieses parlament
endlich vernünftig zusammengesetzt ist
und dieses parlament hat schon mehr
einfluss als früher aber wir streiten
für noch mehr einfluss des europäischen
parlament damit wir nicht europa
missbrauchen wie das gegenwärtig unsere
regierung und andere regierung tun was
machen die denn die benutzten europa und
gewöhnen den leuten deshalb europa ab
und sagen passt mal auf was wir einen
nationalen parlamenten schwer
durchkriegen das vereinbaren wir
regierungschefs als europarecht und dann
kannst du im nationalen parlament nur
noch ja oder nein du kannst nichts
ändern du kannst keinen einfluss nehmen
das ist der trick und sarkozy und merkel
haben das in besonderer weise
praktizieren immer zu zweit sich
verständigt was sich ändern soll und das
lief es läuft nicht ganz so wie mit
sarkozy
aber das war die politik und damit
gewöhnt man doch den leuten europa ab
und nicht an und der ganze süden europas
wird doch kaputt gespielt und ich mache
meine ganz einfache gleichung also wir
sind ja exportweltmeister insgesamt
manchmal sind war vize-weltmeister gibt
ein wettbewerber mit uns dass es china
also entweder ist china weltmeister und
wir viel zu weltmeister oder wiesent
weltmeister denis china vize weltmeister
das wechselt man von jahr zu jahr was
heißt das im klartext im klartext heißt
das dass wir sehr viel mehr herstellen
als wir brauchen wenn wir sehr viel mehr
herstellen als wir brauchen sind wir
darauf angewiesen dass andere länder das
bei uns kaufen wenn wir darauf
angewiesen sind sind wir darauf
angewiesen dass die weniger herstellen
als hier brauchen sonst funktioniert es
nicht und dann müssen wir noch versuchen
relativ preisgünstig zu sein
deshalb haben spd und grüne die agenda
2010 gemacht sie haben die reallöhne
gesenkt sie haben die real renten
gesenkt sie haben die real
sozialleistung gesenkt sie haben die
prekäre beschäftigung eingeführt in
einem maße wie das unter kohl noch gar
nicht denkbar
und warum damit wir im export billiger
werden jetzt leitet übrigens die
eu-kommission untersuchungen gegen
deutschland diesbezüglich ein weil das
ergebnis ist natürlich eine schieflage
es ist übrigens sogar gesetzwidrig es
gibt ein gesetz in dem drinsteht dass
wir einen ausgewogenen haus in handel
haben wollten davon kann ja gar keine
rede sein
nun machen sie folgendes bleiben wir bei
der logik wenn die staaten bei uns
einkaufen sollen aber selber eine
schwache wirtschaft haben weil sie ja
viel weniger herstellen als sie
benötigen dann müssen sie schulden
machen um bei uns die güter kaufen zu
führen und nun werfen wir ihn die
schulden vor die sie zum teil gemacht
haben und bei uns im shop einkaufen zu
können
sie kommt aber ein zweiter gesichtspunkt
hinzu jetzt kommt ja unsere oberschlaue
frau merkel mit ihren beratern und sagt
ihr müsst jetzt runter mit den löhnen
ihr müsst runter mit den renten ihr
müsst viel mehr prekäre beschäftigung
machen usw usw
und das machen sie auch alles ich bin
noch gar nicht bei den banken und dachte
dann werdet ihr wettbewerbsfähig
mal abgesehen von der sozialen kälte die
dahintersteckt überlegen wir uns doch
mal normal
moment mal die werden wirklich
wettbewerbsfähig dann heißt es doch dass
unsere exporte zurück weil sie hat ein
selber verkaufen können nicht mehr so
wie bei uns einkaufen müssen und was
kommt dann die agenda 20 11 was heißt
das wollen wir uns in einen zirkel
begeben wo es heißt immer erst gehen die
länder runter mit löhnen renten mitzählt
radant wieder wir dann sind wir wieder
besser im export dann wieder die wo
wollen wir enden bei null
nun bei 0 rente wo soll das hinführen
wir brauchen das gegenteil erstens
müssen wir unsere wirtschaftsstruktur
dadurch verändern dass wir schritt für
schritt die binnenwirtschaft stärken um
nicht so auf den export angewiesen zu
sein und die binnenwirtschaft können wir
nur stärken mit höheren löhnen höheren
renten höheren sozialleistungen es wird
zeit dass das passiert
und zweitens müssen wir im süden europas
sagen wir braucht einen marshallplan
nicht der abbau des landes ist
entscheidend sondern der aufbau der
länder ist entscheidend das wäre eine
ganz andere struktur natürlich kenne ich
mängel ich kenne korruption in
griechenland das muss man alles keiner
erzählen aber als die jury zahl kurz
davor stand die mehrheit im parlament zu
bekommen da hat ja die bild zeitung und
die regierung und alle darum gekämpft
dass diejenigen in die ganze korruption
eingeführt haben wieder die macht
bekommen das ist ihnen auch gelungen und
das sollen die lösung sein na da kann
man sich nur mehr als wundern kann ich
sagen deshalb und deshalb sage ich wir
müssen dort andere wege gehen
euro als der euro eingeführt wurde gab
es wieder nur über schlaue fraktion und
ich war der doofe weil ich als einziger
sagte für den euro fehlen die bedingen
es gibt keine abgestimmte
wirtschaftspolitik keine abgestimmte
lohnpolitik keine abgestimmte
sozialpolitik damals auch keine
abgestimmte ökologie politik
es gibt völlig unterschiedliche
rechtssysteme wenn man dann eine
binnenwirkung einführt gilt immer der
niedrigste standard und wenn immer der
niedrigste standard geht dann reißt uns
das ganze nach unten und in der krise da
haben die gesagt nein das kriegen wir
alles hin dass alles quatsch was er da
erzählt usw
es ist alles so eingetroffen ich muss es
mal sagen sie hätten jetzt ein mal den
mumm haben können und hätten sagen
können entschuldung sie hatten recht
aber vor ich das höre muss ich 130
werden und das werde ich nicht schaffen
also lege ich auch nicht so viel wert
drauf
aber wichtig ist dass wir gewarnt haben
aber jetzt raus zu gehen aus dem euro
wäre auch falsch weil ich muss es ganz
kurz erklären wenn dann kriegt er das
land wieder seine nationale währung
was dann passiert ist doch klar die
drachme hat dann überhaupt gar kein wert
und die deutsche mark kriegt einen ganz
hohen wert der ganz hohe wert hilft euch
ein bisschen beim sparguthaben oder
sparguthaben ein bisschen mehr wert ist
aber wir werden dann so teuer dass unser
export zusammenbricht und dabei die
bitten wirtschaft gar nicht aufgebaut
haben kriegen wir dann
massenarbeitslosigkeit und alles
mögliche denn sagen mir welche da müssen
wir mit den griechen vereinbaren dass
sie ihre währung nur mit unserer
erlaubnis abwerten dürfen
die werden uns was husten wenn wir die
rausschmeißen aus dem euro lassen sie
sich doch nicht den einzigen vorteil den
sie davon haben nämlich leichter
exportieren zu können nehmen das kann
doch einfach vergessen das wird nicht
passieren
also mit anderen worten das ist jetzt
auch der falsche weg und dann bin ich
eine sache besonders leid die macht der
banken
früher war es mal so banken waren
dienstleister der realwirtschaft die
haben kredite vergeben übrigens auch an
bürgerinnen und bürger heute dominieren
und entscheiden die alles wir dürfen
eines nicht vergessen es gibt eine
weltwirtschaft aber keine
funktionierende weltpolitik und dadurch
gibt es ein primat der finanzwelt über
die politik die chefs der banken
entscheiden was die bundesregierung
macht nicht dass der bundestag
entscheidet was die zu machen und das
war hochinteressant ich saß mal vor drei
jahren weil man wieder bei herrn jauch
und da saß nehmen wir frau koolen die
ard-korrespondentin an der börse sagte
die ergi sie wenn sie bundeskanzler
wären
und die der vorstand der deutschen bank
käme zu ihnen und sagte sie müssen
nächste woche einen insolvenzantrag
stellen noch mal theoretisch an gelungen
müssen sie auch hätten wenn sie sie
nicht retten
ginge die gesamte finanzstruktur der
bundesrepublik kaputt was könnten sie
sich auch nicht leisten
das war interessant dafür habe ich
gesagt zu ihr also abgesehen davon dass
mir die fantasie fehlt mir vorzustellen
dass ich kanzler wäre
werden sie aber recht und wenn sie recht
haben heißt das doch dass der vorstand
der deutschen bank entschieden was ich
als bundeskanzler zu tun hätte und wenn
das stimmt gibt es doch nur zwei
lösungen man muss die großen banken
verkleinern und wie die sparkassen
öffentlich rechtlich gestalten damit sie
wieder zu dienstleistern wäre und ich zu
herrschern unserer gesellschaft das gilt
für ganz europa und brüssel brüssel hat
früher immer gemeckert über die
sparkassen die sagen kein wort mehr
gegen die sparkassen weil die sparkassen
an der krise überhaupt nicht beteiligt
waren
übrigens die raiffeisenbank auch nicht
weiß eine genossenschaftsbank ist muss
man auch mal darüber nachdenken und das
letzte was ich sagen will ist dass ich
es leid bin dass die banken pleite gehen
können wie sie wollen weil alles immer
die steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler
übernehmen wenn ein bäckermeister in
passau kurz vor der insolvenz steht
kommt keiner von der regierung vor bei
uns dafür übernehmen natürlich ihre
schulden aber bei jeder bank kommen wir
vorbei natürlich bezahlen wir alle ja wo
gibt's denn sowas banken müssen endlich
für banken haften das ist doch wohl das
mindeste was er durch sein zu müssen
und übrigens mit begriffen macht man
auch politik und kultur der begriff
staatsschuldenkrise ist völlig falsch
obwohl ich nicht geschreckt erstatten
auch zu viel geld ausgeben das ist nicht
mein problem
es geht um was anderes wir hatten eine
bankenkrise daraufhin haben die staaten
schulden aufgenommen um die banken zu
retten und dann redet man von einer
staatsschuldenkrise in wirklichkeit ist
es aber eine bankenkrise die das ganze
ausgelöst hatten und ich sage noch etwas
was mich auch ungeheuer stört ist was
wir sozial angerichtet haben wir haben
jetzt in griechenland und spanien eine
arbeitslosigkeit von 25 prozent wir
haben eine jugendarbeitslosigkeit in
griechenland von über 60 prozent in
spanien von über 50 prozent
jetzt frage ich mal was soll denn aus
den jungen leuten werden wer bezahlten
die rechnung nachher in zehn zwanzig
jahren ohne ausbildung ohne alles ist es
hanebüchen
die wirtschaftsleistung dank der rezepte
von frau merkel und anderen in
griechenland ist um ein viertel gesunken
die steuereinnahmen gehen zurück wovon
sollen die denn je die schulden
zurückbezahlen kann alles vergessen ich
sage ihnen was irgendwann kommen wird
ein schuldenschnitt und den bezahlen
wenn wir und das hätte man verhindern
können wenn man von anfang an eine
andere politik gemacht hätte nämlich
eine aufbau politik die schulden in
griechenland sind übrigens jetzt von 120
auf 175 prozent gestiegen
gut aber es gibt noch eine zahl die ist
interessant sie muss man sich merken
finde ich ich versuche sie auswendig zu
lernen
die millionäre in der europäischen union
nur die millionäre in der europäischen
union haben ein reines geldvermögen also
ich spreche nicht von unternehmen ich
spreche nicht von immobilien ich spreche
nur von geldvermögen haben ein reines
geldvermögen von 17 millionen euro
die gesamten staatsschulden von allen
kommunen allen bundesländern und allen
staaten betragen elf millionen euro
das heißt selbst wenn wir das 1 1
tauschten behielten methode immer noch 6
millionen euro ich würde mal sagen aber
ich weiß ja dass ich damit nicht
durchkommen aber dass man wenigstens in
europa und in deutschland endlich mehr
steuergerechtigkeit herstellt und sagt
ja millionäre müssen mehr bezahlen und
es gibt auch eine vermögenssteuer mein
gott die tun so als ob die welt davon
untergingen nichts ginge davon unter wir
hätten nur etwas mehr gerechtigkeit was
sie auch dringend benötigen
übrigens auch interessant es gibt ja
immer eine rangfolge der steueroasen
wir reden ja immer gerne über andere
steueroasen wissen sich auf welchem
platz deutschland ist bei den
steueroasen auf platz neun
nur zum vergleich zypern ist auf platz
20 und liechtenstein inzwischen auf
platz 34
wir sind auf platz neun räume ein die
schweiz liegt noch vor uns aber trotzdem
ein starkes stück
ich komme zu unserer gesellschaft zusage
etwas zur armut und reichtum
also wir hatten 1992 ein privates
vermögen von 4 6 millionen 2012 waren es
zehn billionen euro
0 6 prozent unserer haushalte besitzen
davon 20 prozent 0 6 prozent der
haushalte besitzen 20 prozent das sind
zwei millionen euro und die unteren
finanziell unteren 50 prozent der
haushalte besaßen vom vermögen im jahre
1998 4 prozent und im jahre 2012 nur
noch ein prozent also geviertelt so ist
die entwicklung der reichtum nimmt in
immer weniger händen zu und auf der
anderen seite wächst die armut 74
prozent unsere haushalte sind
überschuldet 20 prozent haben gar keinen
fall mehr
das ist die realität
die ersparnisse von arbeitslosen haben
sich mehr als halbiert und zwar deshalb
weil er die bedingungen bei hartz 4 usw
immer so sind dass sie erst ein vermögen
aufbrauchen muss dadurch haben sie
natürlich keine sicherheit keine
rücklagen für das alter nichts kann man
sich alles ausrechnen wollen das läuft
und das deutsche institut für
wirtschaftsforschung wirklich keine
linke einrichtung hat jetzt kritisiert
dass die schieflage in deutschland zu
groß ist und die größte in ganz europa
nirgendwo ist die vermögens- teilung so
ungerecht extrem organisiert in der
europäischen union wie in deutschland
darstellt das deutsche institut für
wirtschaftsforschung fest und sie haben
gesagt sie ärgern sich auch dass man sie
nicht in der lage sind bei dass
statistisch nicht erfasst wird das
wirkliche vermögen der aldis lidls und
anderen milliardäre überhaupt zu
ermitteln also wir sind einsame spitze
bei ungleichheit und wir hatten seit
2001 anstieg bei den vermögenseinkommen
und gewinnen um 62 prozent und bei den
löhnen seit 2000 insgesamt ein minus von
0,7 prozent dass die entwicklung liebe
gewerkschafter ich muss es mal sagen das
haben wir uns alle auch bitten lassen
und das dürfen wir uns nicht bieten
lassen
das muss endlich vorbei sein
auch interessant der anteil der löhne am
gesamten volkseinkommen lag 2003 noch
bei 71 und 2013 nur noch bei 67 prozent
auch das ist wieder interessant weil
wieder die abnahmen angestiegen sind
erzählt er
ja und dann sage ich nur so viel noch
dass deutschland den größten
niedriglohnsektor in europa ich bitte
euch größer als in griechenland größer
größer als in estland als in litauen als
in lettland deutschland hat den größten
niedriglohnsektor und darf ist die spd
auch noch schuld weil sie es
organisierte
und was wird aus den niedriglöhnern ich
frage immer was beziehen sie führen
wovon wollen sie später ihr leben
gestalten
und was wird aus zehn kindern denn
niedrig es gibt für mich ein grundsatz
der ist so wichtig chancengleichheit für
kinder
ich möchte dass die talente eines jeden
kindes gefördert werden dass jedes kind
die gleichen chancen auf bildung hat
ganz egal ob die mutter alexij ii
empfängerin ist oder ob der vater
professor an der universität ist beide
kinder müssen das recht haben dass ihre
begabung gefördert wird und wir haben
ein höchst ungerechtes bildungssystem
dass chancengleichheit nicht mal im
ansatz herstellt und ich sag das ja auch
in bayern weil man hier so stolz auf das
eigene bildungssystem mein gott 16
verschiedene schulsysteme weil wir 16
bundesländer haben passen hervorragend
das bestreite ich ja nicht ins 19
jahrhundert aber mit dem 21 jahrhundert
an sie wirklich nichts aber auch gar
nichts zu tun was müssen wir endlich
überwinden chancengleichheit in der
bildung für alle kinder vorher in
nordbayern zu steuern bin ich auch etwas
an
jetzt werden sich vielleicht wundern
aber das problem bei uns besteht darin
dass die mitte der gesellschaft alles
bezahlen der finanziell untere teil kann
es ja gar nicht obwohl ich immer diesen
satz so blöde finde dass die
spitzenverdiener die meisten steuern
bezahlen dann nehmen wir nur die
einkommenssteuer auch eine
hartz-iv-empfängerin muss zum beispiel
mehrwertsteuer bezahlen was einkauft und
wenn sie raucht muss auch noch tabak
steuer bezahlen und wenn sie an einer
tankstelle mal sein sollte muss er auch
benzin steuern bezahlen also alle
möglichen besteuern muss man bezahlen
auch wichtig zu wissen
in deutschland gibt es eine verschiebung
von den einkommenssteuern hin zu den
verbrauchssteuern die pawo aus steuern
sind immer gestiegen worden und zwar bei
dass wir alle bezahlen müssen
da triffst du nicht die reichen
er kaufte er nicht mehr es gibt übrigens
noch ein interessanten unterschied wenn
du eine hartz-iv-empfängerin zehn euro
mehr gibt es gibt die zehn euro mehr aus
wenn du einen milliardär zehn euro mehr
gibt es spekulierte für zehn euro mehr
er stärkt nicht die binnenwirtschaft er
hat schon alles auch interessant
volkswirtschaftlich der unterschied aber
wie gesagt ich sage die mitte der
gesellschaft bezahlt alles und deshalb
haben wir einen vorschlag zur
entwicklung der einkommenssteuer gemacht
der gar nicht dazu führte dass wir mehr
einnahmen hätten wir hätten nicht mehr
einnahmen wir hätten nur eine gerechtere
verteilung innerhalb der
einkommenssteuer denn unsere
einkommenssteuer hat ja nicht nur sie
kennen den begriff der kalten
progression das bedeutet dass brutto
dein lohn sagen wir mal um zehn prozent
steigt ich mach mal extrem aber netto
nur um zwei prozent
und das liegt wiederum an der steuer das
ist die kalte progression das ist ein
problem kann man überwinden sollte man
überwinden haben sie vorher versprochen
machen sie aber nicht haben sie schon
gesagt es erledigt auf der anderen seite
aber haben wir einen so genannten
mittelstandsbauch und das liegt daran
dass unsere einkommenssteuer nicht so
verläuft sondern die hat hier so ein
bauch und der bauch ist die mitte der
gesellschaft
und zwar weil unten können sie nicht
mehr wegnehmen und an die reichen trauen
sie sich nicht ran oder wollen nicht
rein
oder beides wollen nicht und freuen sich
nicht und dadurch bezahlt die mitte
alles wer ist die mitte es ist die
lehrerin und der lehre
das ist die facharbeiterin und der
facharbeiter das ist die meisterin und
der meister das ist auch die polizistin
und der polizist wie es ist die gesamte
mitte der gesellschaft
wenn doch die mitte der gesellschaft
endlich begriffen dass die linke ihre
interessen vertritt keiner sonst
verlangt dass dieser steuer bauch welt
und der kann nur weg gehen wenn ich den
spitzensteuersatz für höhere und das
ganze ausgleich und sagen ein oben muss
mehr bezahlt werden
nicht die mitte hat die gesellschaft zu
besuchen ist doch eine einfache lösung
da könnten doch erst mal alle
bäckermeister sein da hat er recht
und dann sollten uns auch wählen
also über die bonisteuer habe ich schon
gesprochen prekäre beschäftigung mein
gott
60 prozent aller unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer in deutschland sind übrigens
für einen flächendeckenden gesetzlichen
mindestlohn
das ist wirklich ein fortschritt also 40
prozent sind natürlich noch dagegen aber
60 prozent sind dafür hat eine forsa
umfrage geben und dann haben sie gefragt
die linien die für einen
flächendeckenden gesetzlichen
mindestlohn sind wie hoch dieser sein
soll
und wissen sie was die durchschnitts
forderung der unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer ist 888 euro sage ich nur
mal in richtung spd grüne und
gewerkschaften also mit euren 850 euro
liegt er unter dem vorschlag der
unternehmen wollte ich natürlich auch
unter unserem vorschlag aber wichtig ist
mir jetzt dass er kommt der
flächendeckende gesetzliche mindestlohn
ist eine notwendigkeit wir müssen damit
ich nicht falsch verstanden bin ich bin
ja für tarifautonomie und gewerkschaften
und unternehmen können immer vereinbaren
dass sie mehr bezahlen
der gesetzgeber muss nur eine mindest
untergrenze setzen und sagen wenn ja
darf pro stunde in deutschland nicht
bezahlt werden und punkt und die anderen
können immer mehr vereinbaren dass es
ihre sache aber weniger darf nicht
bezahlt werden
es gibt es natürlich ein riesen streit
von union mit spd über ausnahmen ich
will bloß folgendes sagen wenn sich die
ausnahmen durchsetzen die auch seehofer
will dann haben wir nicht mehr fünf
millionen menschen die einen höheren
lohn beziehen sondern nur noch 3 mio das
heißt für fast die hälfte 42 millionen
wird dann der gesetzliche mindestlohn
gestrichen das ist beim besten willen
nicht hinnehmbar
und das muss auch schluss sein dass man
mit billiger arbeit profite
erwirtschaftet arbeit hat ihren wert und
letztlich die arbeit schafft die werte
nichts anderes die arbeit schafft die
werte und deshalb brauchen wir auch
wieder eine strenge anbindung der
lohnentwicklung an die
produktivitätsentwicklung und übrigens
auch der rentenentwicklung an die
lohnentwicklung auch das muss ich wieder
hin und sagt wo es lang arbeit hat sich
die große koalition vorgenommen auf 18
monate zu befristen ab 19 monate muss
das arbeitsverhältnis unbefristet werden
dann haben sie gesagt neun monate dürfen
leiharbeiterinnen und leiharbeiter
wesentlich schlechter bezahlt werden
aber ab zehnten monat müssen wir den
gleichen lohn haben was heißt das für
die unternehmen wenn ich es verhindern
will muss ich nach neun monaten den
leiharbeiter wechseln und wenn ich einen
habe wo ich wirklich mehr bezahlen muss
aber spätestens nach 18 monaten und die
anstehenden unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer übernehmen sowieso und die
unanständigen werden das genau nutzen um
dann mit diesen tricks das ganze zu
umgehen das hilft nicht fand anfang also
erstens bin ich ja sowieso gegen
leiharbeit
aber wenn ich jetzt in
koalitionsverhandlungen mit der spd wäre
was ich entgegen vielen
pressemitteilungen noch nicht bin
also wenn dann würde ich sagen würde ich
sagen ja okay aus nahm aber dann machen
wir eine ausnahme wir machen
französisches recht wenn sie sagen was
heißt das und dann würde ich sagen ja da
hat jede leiharbeiterinnen und jeder
leiharbeiter vom ersten tag an anspruch
auf einen lohn von 110 prozent dessen
was jemand aus der stammbelegschaft für
die gleiche tätigkeit bekommen verdient
zehn prozent mehr und zwar weil er nicht
immer einen job hat sie eine begründung
und die zweite ist es soll ja eine
bestrafung sein damit es sicher ist es
wird wirklich nur in ausnahmefällen
gemacht wenn ihm ein elektromeister
kranke soll ich brauche dringend ein
elektromeister dann mache ich das eben
und da muss ich ihr mehr bezahlen dann
kümmere ich mich um die gesundheit
meines electric meistert weil der viel
günstiger ist diese ausnahme damit
könnte ich leben aber so wie es jetzt
organisiert ist es unerträglich und da
hilft das nicht passt die große
koalition fort außerdem außerdem müssen
wir unbedingt den missbrauch der
werkverträge unterbinden dazu steht gar
nicht im koalitionsvertrag und dann muss
ich sagen auch die befristeten
arbeitsverträge gehen mir auf die nerven
das sind ja 12 das sind über vier
millionen und es sind bei den jungen
beschäftigten die hälfte die hälfte und
jetzt kommt dann also die union und
tötet mir die ohren voll und sagt immer
wir kriegen wissenschaftlich heißt das
die einfache reproduktion der
bevölkerung nicht hin
übersetzt bedeutet das dass jedes jahr
mehr deutsche sterben als geboren werden
das heißt die deutschen eben immer ab
und das findet die union gar nicht gut
deshalb überlegen sich ja fachkräfte aus
der dritten welt zu holen
vergessen allerdings dass vielleicht die
dritte welt auf die fachkräfte auch
angewiesen ist aber mal ganz abgesehen
davon kommt ja noch was hinzu dass ich
ihn immer sage wie sie sollen kinder
also die erwachsenen kinder kriegen dann
sage ich also erstens glaube ich im
unterschied zur union nicht dass sie es
handwerklich verlernt haben sondern wenn
dann geht es um andere sachen
wenn sie mir das glauben bin ich ja
schon schritt weiter und dann sage ich
also wir haben zwei junge leute in
befristeten arbeitsvertrag für drei
monate oder vor vier monaten die wissen
gar nicht muss er danach
arbeitsverhältnis waren ansonsten kinder
in die welt setzen
dann verliert in der regel die frau
irgendwie ihre tätigkeit mit kindern
kommt dann auch nicht wieder rein
alles nicht geregelt dann das
bildungssystem sprach ich schon davon
wenn er darum ziehst um job zu haben
musste dein kind dann eine ganz andere
schule schicken auch abenteuerlich wir
sind nicht kinderfreundlich die ganze
gesellschaft ist nicht kinderfreundlich
organisiert die beste tat von frau
merkel war folgende bei mir waren auch
mal als anwalt leute ältere die
beschwerten sich dass dein
kinderspielplatz ist
und ob ich für sie klage gegen den
kinderspielplatz weiter zu laut ist
gesagt mach ja vieles aber das mach ich
noch nicht ich weiß nicht wohin mit den
kindern formen sollen die nicht spielen
dürfen
es gibt doch mal aber dabei haben sie
sicher auch das lärmschutzgesetz
gestützt und hatten erfolg bei gericht
und dann hat merkel macht in einer
großtat gesagt wir ändern das gesetz
unterschreiben reim kinderlärms gar kein
lärm und dadurch dass es trotz drin
steht ist das vorbei aber da brauchst du
schon wieder einen anlauf um sowas zu
regeln wenn wir keine kinderfreundliche
gesellschaft bekommen dann werden wir
auch viel zu wenig kinder haben das ist
das ergebnis also müssen wir investieren
und zwar vor allen dingen in
kindertagesstätten netze und in bildung
und kindertagesstätten netze heißt
erzieherinnen und erzieher und ausbilden
und endlich gut bezahlen anzuerkennen
dass der beruf der lehrerin und des
lehrers ein schwerer berufes ich
akzeptiere auch nicht dass
gymnasiallehrer so viel mehr verdient
als grundschullehrer bringen doch
erstmal so sexuellen lesen und schreiben
bei das ist nicht viel einfacher als
nachher irgendwas in der physik zu
erklären also sage ich mir
die müssen gleich starten auch von der
bezahlung wir müssen wirklich in bildung
in jeder hinsicht investieren und
wenigstens mal das kooperationsverbot
aufheben der bund muss auch herangezogen
werden können für bildung und das müssen
wir erreichen
also wenn ich
deshalb treten wir dafür ein dass wir
sagen befristete arbeitsverhältnisse
wenn es dafür eine sachgrund gibt aber
nicht willkürlich und gegenwärtig ist
willkürlich lass mich noch kurz was zur
rente sagen das sind ja alles
abenteuerliche sachen die wir dort
erleben
also erstens die rente ab 67 bleibt
dahinter steckt die logik der demografie
und diese bundestagsdebatten liebig dann
stehen die immer vorne und sagen unsere
menschen werden immer älter das ist ja
zu begrüßen aber und das aber klingt
dann so als ob man so ab meinem alter
doch mal bei rot über die kreuzung gehen
laut und das meinen sie natürlich nicht
und sagen immer und deshalb bei die
demografie so läuft muss nochmal später
rente zahlen was schäuble immer gesagt
die 67 erst der anfang habe ich ihn
gefragt wo das endet wollte mir nicht
sagen wollte wissen bei 87 oder wo war
dann aufhören aber habe ich keine
antwort darauf bekommen und die frage
ist ist die logik richtig ich höre ja
immer zu also ich höre mir auch die
logik der anderen an weil es genügt ja
nicht dass ich einfach dagegen bin ich
muss eine andere logik aufbauen und ich
glaube die logik ist falsch weil die
demographie gar nicht entscheidend
entscheidend ist die
produktivitätsentwicklung und die
produktivitätsentwicklung ist so groß
dass wir uns selbstverständlich wieder
eine rente ab 65 leisten könnten wenn
denn die große koalition wenigstens mal
zu einer großen reform fähig wäre
die wir dringend benötigen und die große
reform besteht darin das war erstens
wieder die alte formel 1 führen dass man
dafür dass man erwerbsgemindert ist kein
abzug bei der rente erlebt dass man
wieder ganz eng bindet die
rentenentwicklung an die lohn- und die
lohnentwicklung an die
produktivitätsentwicklung und dass man
dann sagt ja die zeiten sind vorbei
müssen wir der jungen generation sagen
die zeiten sind vorbei wo nur
lohnabhängig beschäftigten und deren
unternehmen in die rentenversicherung
einzahlen
alle mit erwerbseinkommen müssen
einzahlen auch bundestagsabgeordneter
auch rechtsanwälte auch beamtinnen und
beamte alle müssen
anders geht wenn wir da hin wenn wir
dann sagen und die
beitragsbemessungsgrenze wird aufgegeben
während eine million verdient muss im
beitrag von millionen bezahlen
und wenn wir dann als drittes noch
sagten und wir machen für die
spitzenverdiener eine renten anstiegs
abflachung ich erkläre es gleich dann
wäre alles zu finanzieren
zwar ist es so in der schweiz gibt seine
höchstrente also die haben also drei
renten da müssen übrigens alle einzahlen
auch unbegrenzt vom ganzen einkommen ja
ich meine sonst ist die schweiz nicht
vor bild.de fragt kann man auch was von
ihr lernen und wir nehmen aus sei und
dann haben die höchstgrenze das haben
natürlich auch welche meiner fraktion
vorgeschlagen aber ich kenne ja unser
bundesverfassungsgericht und das würde
sagen höhere beiträge müssen auch zu
höheren rente führen
und da ich ja mit denen gar nicht in
kollisionen geraten will haben wir
gesagt dann machen wir aber etwas was
sie zu lassen dass man nämlich den
rentenanstieg nachher abflacht weil sie
sagen es ist ja eine solidarische
versicherung deshalb kann er nicht
erwarten dass die rente so steigert wie
seine beiträge sich steigen
ja und wir hätten alles gelöst wir
brauchten über altersarmut nicht zu
diskutieren und stattdessen wird nur das
alter verschoben dann meine kleine
korrektur wie jetzt bei den 63 jährigen
wenn es dann wirklich gesetz wird warten
wir noch ab und um da auch was zu sagen
es ist natürlich auch wieder jetzt
kriege ich viele briefe von denen die
mit 63 in rente gegangen sind und ab zu
haben ob sie denn den abzug behalten
natürlich verhalten dir den abzug
das gilt ja dann nur für die fälle die
danach in das alter kommen und vor allem
stimmt auch der begriff nicht der
begriff ist wieder falsch weil wir noch
die rente ab 67 schon beschlossen haben
sodass sich das immerzu verschiebt
nachher darfst du mit 65 in rente gehen
wenn du 45 beitragsjahre hass und die
anderen erst mit 67 also ist der begriff
63 schon falsch aber das lasse ich mir
auch alles weg ich muss muss noch was
vermieter rente sagen erstens ist es ein
oberbegriff zum beispiel weil ich die
theoretisch auch bezüge keine mutter bin
wohlig feministin entschuldigt mal die
taz hat mich gefragt ob es männer gibt
die feministen sein können habe ich
gesagt nein mit einer ausnahme nämlich
ich aber sie haben eine ironie nicht
verstanden aber es macht ja nicht aber
es macht er mit nein ich will auch was
anderes hinaus wir sagen kinder vor 92
geboren bekommen bisher also die mütter
oder gelegentlich auch die peter
bekommen ein rentner eckwert punkt
anerkannt und bei kindern ab 92 nicht
nach ab 92 bekommen dreiländereck wird
punkt nun sagt die koalition dass es
ungerecht das ist doch ungerecht weil es
ja vor 92 nicht leichter aber kinder
aufzuziehen alten saab 92 also sagen sie
wir machen jetzt vor 92 2 renten eckwert
punkte sie sagen nicht 3 das heißt nach
wie vor selbst wenn das dann eines tages
beschlossen sein sollte bekommst du für
ein kind das vor 92 geworden dass
weniger geld als für ein kind das ab 92
geboren
aber nicht nur das sondern ich muss es
jetzt mal hier sagen es geht um die
eckwert punkte
und die sind im osten geringer als im
westen und das bedeutet dass du für ein
kind im osten weniger kristalls für ein
kind im westen
das ist absurd ich sage das auch ganz
klar in bayern das ist absurd und nicht
hinnehmbar und das empfinden die leute
auch nicht als gerecht wir brauchen den
gleichen wert für kinder ganz egal ob
sie in thüringen bayern in mecklenburg
vorpommern oder in hessen geboren worden
jetzt kommt aber der wirkliche höhepunkt
der wirkliche höhepunkt ist dass sie das
aus den beiträgen finanzieren nicht aus
steuermitteln
und das heißt im klartext dass die
verkäuferinnen becker mit ihren
beiträgen diese mütter rente bezahlt und
der bäckermeister mit den
lohnnebenkosten diese rente ebenfalls
bezahlt und es heißt im klartext dass
meine lidl kassiererin ist bezahlt und
der bundestagsabgeordnete nimmt an der
bezahlung nicht teil
denn wir sind ja nicht gesetzlich
rentenversichert und zahlen keine
beiträge
das ist absurd dafür dass du ein kind
bekommt zeit für nicht höhere beiträge
das hat denn mit den beiträgen nichts zu
tun das ist eine gesellschaft für deine
familie für dich selbst und es ist eine
eine leistung für die gesamte
gesellschaft deshalb muss eine solche
mütter rente selbstverständlich aus
steuermitteln bezahlt werden damit die
bundestagsabgeordnete und alle anderen
sich daran beteiligen und nicht sagen
ihr beitrags hat das ganze finanziert
das ist immer das was sie jetzt
beschlossen hat dass sie beschlossen
und zum schluss war mittwoch ist und es
auch ein bisschen unterhalten sein soll
erzähle ich euch einen witz der ihm
schon im kindergarten erzählt worden ist
der betrifft mich und ihr könnt ja dann
beurteilen wie empfindet also auf jeden
fall kommt eine ganze gruppe von
terroristen in den bundestag
schreit wo ist der gysi die beamten
leicht eingeschüchtert sagen im plenum
dann kommen die ins plenum sind
natürlich alle mit masken und
maschinenpistolen und brüllend laut wer
ist denn hier der gysi
ich merke dass ich ja nun keine chance
mehr habe stehe ich also freiwillig auf
und sah ich dann sagt er du meine meine
fraktion meine fraktion hat eben so
gelacht wie hier und da hab ich gesagt
ich glaube ihr habt den witz nicht
richtig verstanden nur ich darf mich
doch lange wird